now now I saw the movie Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon
I saw the movie Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon I was surprised because I didn't
see any Tigers or Dragons and then I
realized why they're crouching and
hidden and now it's time to give the
award for our best makeup and it's
ironic that this award for best makeup
is given by someone who doesn't need any
here she is Kate Hudson
whoever said you can't make a silk purse
out of a sow's ear should have given the
job to a movie makeup artist even though
they're magicians they still can't make
a performer taller or shorter younger or
older but they can make a performer look
taller shorter younger older or even
something else for best achievement in
the constantly advancing art of makeup
consider this in the cell Jennifer Lopez
the child psychiatrist who dares to
enter the twisted mind of a serial
killer played by Vincent D'Onofrio this
fantastic journey has made all the more
chilling by the makeup creations of
nominees Michelle Burke and Edouard and
Rica's inspired by the whimsical
drawings of the ever-popular dr. Seuss
nominees Rick Baker and Gail Ryan spent
three hours every day turning Jim Carrey
into that mean old Yuletide thief The
Grinch who stole Christmas based on the
original film Nosferatu and it's
real-life star Max Schreck
nominees and Buchanan and amber Sibley
took Willem Dafoe and transformed him
into a bloodthirsty creature of the
night in shadow of the vampire
and the Oscar goes to Rick Baker and Gil
ride the doctoral students how the
grinch stole christmas
Rick Baker's sixth Academy Award it is
the first Oscar and nomination for Gayle
Ryan in 1981 Baker received the first
Oscar for makeup for an American
Werewolf in London
thank you Jason we'd like to thank the
Academy Universal imagine Brian Grazer
and Ron Howard for making such a
creative film the entire cast for their
patience and cooperation Jim Carrey for
his brilliant performance my crew over
150 talented people contributed greatly
to the work that we accept this award
for and I'm sorry I can't thank them all
individually but one I have to thank
tonight is Kazuhiro Tsuji
kazoo not only applied Jim Carrey's
Grinch makeup but design many of the
makeups and deserves to be here with us
lastly I like to think the love's in my
life
my beautiful wife Sylvia my fantastic
daughters Veronica and Rebecca
my late mother Doris in my father Ralph
I'd also like to thank my fabulous crew
a special thanks to Terry belly ale for
his wonderful work tell my husband I
love him and Laurel I wish you were here
thank you
for a special award a special action
Oscar winner Dustin Hoffman
you